so you long time Dave Ramsey show
listeners who does Dave Ramsey suggest
you bank with who does Dave Ramsey
suggest you bank with small community
banks regional banks at the most and
credit unions we suggest you stay away
from the mega banks the Wells Fargo's
the Chase's god help you if you're a
Bank of America and so on why because
they're all horrible human beings no we
don't nothing like that at all if you
work at one of those places I'm sorry
for you but those places have lost their
business soul meaning that all you are
is a number I mean you're at a bank
literally all you are is a number but
you will get very low service in almost
every case you will find bad customer
service in almost every case and you
will find extreme levels of marketing
from them selling you aggressively debt
as one of the grows most aggressively
marketed products in the culture today
so I don't have anything to do with
major national banks except tell you not
to use them the big boys so to speak I
just named Chase Bank of America Wells
Fargo that's the three that come to mind
these big mega banks why you would do
business with them as beyond me they
can't make a decision their service is
bad I mean they're the airline industry
of the banking world that's what they
are you stand in line to give them your
money it does not make sense to me at
all
so I've told you that for what how long
have I been on the air 25 years I've
said the exact same thing for 25 years
now the names have changed because some
of the banks have gone out of business
and some of them of all to each other
out but you know that's what I've told
you over and over and over again so now
have you seen this
breaking news story over the last few
weeks on Wells Fargo Wells Fargo has
been fined let me look at this article
again what make sure I get that number
right it's unbelievable
she's at 85 million 85 millions what
they were fined in 2011 I 185 million
they just found 185 million dollars for
opening fraudulent accounts and moving
customers money so in other words if
Dave Ramsey had an account there which
he doesn't they would open another Dave
Ramsey account move my money from my
account into my account so I didn't lose
the money I just now had two accounts
why in the world would you do that I
mean they didn't the people didn't put
money in their pocket by doing that oh
yeah they did because they have
compensation incentive plans based on
the number of accounts that they open
and so they would fraudulently open
accounts just to drive their own
personal compensation now
Wells Fargo is its it is a soulless
entity meaning it does not it's not good
and it's not bad in and of itself it's
just a large institution that is very
poorly run there's two hundred and
sixty-five thousand employees that's how
big it is that's amazing and so what I
mean did like three or four people open
these fraudulent accounts and so the
federal government comes in and says
you're gonna pay hundred eighty five
million dollars in fines no listen to
this
they fired five thousand three hundred
people that did this that's a small town
they fired five thousand three hundred
people and so far it looks like as best
I haven't found an article that says
that any management got fired only these
port doofuses who are running around
trying to up their paycheck falsely by
just moving your money around if you
work there so people have been to
eating me and emailing me Dave shall
take my money out of Wells Fargo should
I take money out of Wells Fargo well
yeah you should take your money out of
Bank of America you should take your
money how to chase you shouldn't had it
in there in the first place because I've
never told you to have it there in the
first place so why would I change today
of course you need to move it but maybe
this is your wake-up call for some of
you five thousand three hundred people
now I gotta you know it's not a big
percentage what is that that's is that
is it ten percent would be twenty six
thousand and so this is like two percent
of their employees are absolute crooks
I mean crooks but I mean two percent of
your employees could be crooks I mean if
you had a hundred people there'll be two
people you were crooks it's not like
it's a big deal but it's a big deal
because it's your money
why are you doing business there they
all have not they all but a lot of
financial institutions have incentives
based on the account to be open but who
in the world thinks you just go and open
up somebody's account without their
permission in their name they take your
social security number in your name and
go open an account move money over there
your money over there so that they would
get a bonus for opening accounts that's
all it was but five thousand three
hundred of them did it and I don't know
how much money was involved I guess
everybody got their money back as best I
can tell I haven't seen an article that
states otherwise and I haven't studied
this particular fraudulent transaction
in detail I've read through for the
articles that are out there floating
around but five thousand three our
people got fired I don't know where you
come from but where I come from I think
that's a big deal so I'll repeat it
again who does Dave Ramsey say you ought
to do banking with well I endorsed in
several cities that we broadcast in
credit unions and I endorse in several
cities that we broadcast in small
community local banks and a few regional
banks here or there and I personally do
business with both a small community
bank and a regional bank and I get great
service out of both and if either one of
them start acting like they don't have a
soul or a brain I will punt them like
last week's football baby I mean they'll
be gone right straight through the
uprights
we'll be done
so I mean it's real simple but you can
tell by the way you're treated if you
feel like you are trying to get on an
airplane when you're going to one of
these banks and you know you got a bad
Bank with the exception of maybe trying
to get on Southwest right I mean you
understand we're talking about people
that don't give a rep is what I'm
talking about that all they care about
is their own little incentive plans and
all they care about what they can sell
you not how they can serve you and of
course with any industry with any
business if that's what you get then get
away from folks I don't mind people
selling stuff I sell stuff but you need
to sell stuff in the mindset of what
you're doing is there to serve the
customer I truly believe when you buy
Total Money Makeover book you have been
served that you have been helped a whole
lot more if you read the book that you
bought then the cost of the book you
will make many many fold or return on
investment on that so I feel like I'm
serving you and I'm not just doing it
just to make a sale and we don't have
anybody around here just to make a sale
people around here get in just to make a
sale mode we get them out of the
building because we don't sell we serve
but I want you to serve a lot meaning
sell a lot and so I'm not against sales
don't misunderstand but I am definitely
definitely definitely against the mega
banks wouldn't do business with them I
don't want my name in on their grid
where they can track me any more than
they already do from the other
transactions that I do that allow them
access to information just moving around
the web and stuff so that's what
happened with Wells Fargo it's a pretty
simple scam and no I mean I read one
article titled Wells Fargo's rotten to
the core they're not writing the core
265 thousand people there's some good
people there too but there's 5300 crooks
now looking for jobs and somehow they
got away with not firing management I
don't know how leadership doesn't get
blamed for putting in place programs and
doesn't have checks and balances to make
sure fraudulent accounts are being
opened up to where the Fed comes in
federal government comes in and finds it
and finds them 185 million dollars well
Wow so there you go folks
just a good time to buy local you know
you're banking by local this is the Dave
Ramsey show
hey guys Rachel Cruz here hope you
enjoyed that video from the Dave Ramsey
show if you want to watch another great
video check out my video three things
you should consider renting right over
here or click the link in the
description below